[Music]
hey everyone its Alicia Malone this is
Fandango indie movie Guide the only show
that lets you know about these small
films you can see in cinemas and at home
this week let's dive right into it with
Jessica Chastain in the zookeepers wife
this one has been on my radar as one of
my most anticipated films of the year
it's based on a best-selling book and
it's directed by Niki Caro who did Whale
Rider Jessica Chastain plays the
zookeepers wife that's in the title it's
all set in 1939 Poland telling the true
story of a zookeeper and his wife who
helped shelter Jewish people during the
Holocaust there are people I know people
trying to help
they have trucks they have guns and they
want to use the zoo as a way station
what do you mean a place to hide choose
until safe houses can be found for them
they saved hundreds of lives so this is
a really beautiful moving story it's
shot really well and I love Jessica
Chastain in everything she does she
brings so much humanity to every role
it's also interesting to look at this
film in terms of the parallels between
humans and animals it makes you think
about how humans are especially cruel to
other humans and often treat humans much
worse than they treat animals there's
also something very pure about the
nature of animals that Jessica
Chastain's character really taps into
Hollywood love stories about world war 2
but this is one I had never heard of and
it is beautifully told so check out the
zookeepers wife in select theaters this
weekend VP that's why I love animals so
much
you look in the rice
[Music]
continue exactly what's in their arms
what have you been up to in your little
zoo from war to the afterlife the
discovery is directed by Charlie
McDowell who was behind that brilliant
little indie the one I love this
explores similar themes in terms of it
being a sci-fi romance that will make
you think but it's much more ambitious
it goes much deeper to look at loss
grief and the afterlife it stars Robert
Redford who plays a doctor who discovers
there might be something better for
humans after they die which leads to a
lot of people committing suicide years
later his son played by Jason Segel
ghostfinger's estate and discovers a
cult-like following that his father has
and he also meets a beautiful young
woman played by Rooney Mara we opened
the door for these people now we have to
show the voice behind it
the brilliant casting director really
ground this film so it never strays into
unrealistic territory it's out on
Netflix and in select theaters but this
is one you'll want to see with someone
else there's so many unanswered
questions that you'll really want to
talk about and finally Kari pill be a
sweet little coming-of-age film starring
British actress Belle Polly who you may
remember from the Diary of a teenage
girl
[Music]
baby I'm not really in the right frame
of mind to make flirty chitchat with a
total stranger I just want to know if I
can borrow this chair oh definitely yes
Kari is a very smart girl who graduated
Harvard when she was 18 but she doesn't
have any relationships or friendships
her therapist along with her father set
her a task of things to do in order to
try to get her out of her shell the
script spouts a lot about literature and
it could almost be a little bit
pretentious if it weren't for Belle
Polly she makes this movie really
charming you'll want to go along on the
journey with her character as she
discovers who she really is starts to
let people in and mend some old trauma
great supporting cast - a really fun
watch check out Carrie pill be in
theaters or on video and demands
contrary to what the degrees on the wall
may imply I don't have all the answers I
wouldn't trust anyone who thought that
they did
[Music]
what did you do when you were six I
wrote several strongly worded letters to
oil companies Wow three fantastic little
films that each explore very big topics
war the afterlife the meaning of life
make sure you see the zookeepers wife in
theaters the discovery on Netflix or in
theaters and carry pill be in theaters
or at home on video and demand as always
I love to hear from you so let me know
in the comments below or on Twitter at
Alicia Malone which movies you're most
looking forward to seeing this week I'll
see you soon
[Music]